new york democrats blocking a motion to
subpoena the state department of health
for full records this after a bombshell
report reveals the state
undercounted nursing home deaths by
nearly 50 percent
it all comes as nine of governor cuomo's
top health officials
quit joining me now new york post
columnist carol
markowitz carol what possible reason
could democrats have
for blocking this subpoena other than
quite frankly covering up the truth
well it's politics and you know governor
cuomo has long been
known as quite a bully so i think that a
lot of it is that they're just afraid of
him
also it's hard to overlook that he still
enjoys
quite a good approval rating so they
would be taking a chance
if they opposed him and these aren't
politicians who take chances and these
aren't politicians who
speak their minds or go out on a limb to
do the right thing they're
part of a political system and they're
going to stay that way
there is though one democrat who appears
to have gone out on a limb and that of
course is
a.g leticia james here in new york she
did
blow this open do you think she'll
subpoena these records
you know it's possible and i am very
proud of what attorney
general james did but you know anybody
who was watching this program
knew this story already i was on your
show so many times talking about the
numbers and how they were obviously
flawed because they were only counting
nursing home deaths that happened in
nursing homes if a nursing home patient
was taken to a hospital and died there
that wasn't counted
if they died on the way to the hospital
that wasn't counted and so we knew for
so long that this was completely flawed
and just incorrect numbers
her investigation is obviously you know
a very good thing that
it puts the story front and center to
people but i'm just saying this is
well known already and this is not
something that just came up or was just
found out
while we here at fox news knew about it
reported on it the rest of the media
didn't report on it instead praising
governor cuomo and his quote-unquote
emmy-winning press conferences
including this little ditty we dug up
from the archives msnbc's nicole wallace
tweeting this from the middle of march
of last year
quote people will watch this new york
governor cuomo presser when they study
crisis leadership especially his remarks
about
misinformation being more dangerous than
the virus do you think now the media is
going to begin to hold him accountable
they seem like they might start i don't
have a lot of faith however
his brother was famously his main
interviewer throughout the crisis
they gave him softball interviews when
he launched his book on leadership in
the middle of the pandemic
and so i don't see a giant shift in the
way the media treats him
i think that they'll play some lip
service to this report but i i don't see
a giant
change on this now but you did see a
giant q-tip using anchor props to
discuss a pandemic that killed
so many so many thousands of people
meantime you have a new op
ed out call the future is florida why do
you say that
well florida's been open throughout most
of this pandemic
and they've been doing great and it's
not just pandemic policies but it is
again going back to leadership
governor desantis in florida decided
that businesses
and schools most importantly should be
open and they have been
and their numbers mirror new york
california numbers who
are pretty tightly closed you know going
back to the
politicians who have a backbone governor
desantis didn't want to see
his state's businesses in ruins and it's
not just about business policies it's
about people policies because
schools were so important to this
equation and his
insistence that schools be opened is
that's actually something that
other governors should study and look
into
carol it's not just the retirees that
are talking about this now
people are are saying hey you know maybe
we make a break for it now before we're
the last one turning out the lights
we'll see you're absolutely right carol
marcus yeah we talk about it all the
time
the future's floored it's crazy carol
markowitz we appreciate your time as
always thanks so much